[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 y más romeros alaya está
conmigo en el estudio mar vamos a hablar
de un tema que nos quita el sueño
literalmente y con esto madrugones que
nos pegamos para informar a toda la
audiencia pues es prudente hablar del
sueño y por qué es tan importante para
nuestra salud y raúl de hecho quería
empezar preguntándote si has dormido
bien o yo no mira yo creo que duermo un
aproximado de cinco horas la verdad no
les tengo malas noticias para ti o morir
o que pues tampoco pero quizás quizás
deberíamos empezar a plantearnos estos
esquemas de sueño que nos hace también
pues este trabajo debemos decir que
empezamos a trabajar a las cuatro y
media de la mañana toda esta información
preparada para ustedes pero bueno
volviendo al tema que nos ocupa por qué
es importante dormir para nuestra salud
para empezar pues contamos con la
opinión de expertos entrevistamos a
paula que avanzó que es neurólogo
colombiana y esto fue lo que nos dijo el
sueño es importante porque es el momento
en el que el cerebro digamos no
solamente descansa sino trabaja más es
el momento donde se hace como por
decirlo así un recicla y todo lo que hay
durante el día
y una depuración digamos de muchas cosas
que suceden y logramos
seleccionar algunas de las cosas más
importantes y donde se activan muchas
funciones durante el sueño el cerebro
las activa a nivel sistémico para que
podamos digamos funcionar al otro día
para funcionar al otro día precisamente
es la recomendación de la doctora por lo
que tenemos que dormir bien pero
repasemos esas fases y esos ciclos del
sueño hay varias que implican que tienen
además distintas funciones no para
empezar está el momento en el que se
pasa de la vigilia a la primera fase de
dormir que puede durar sólo unos cinco
minutos pero que es importante para
entrar en que cuando uno siente que se
está como cayendo exacto de hecho eso
son unas como funciones del cerebro como
ondas de energía que manda precisamente
porque el cerebro piensa que podemos
estar en una situación de peligro tras
este tiempo de hecho es el que toma el
cerebro en acostumbrarse y saber que lo
que está pasando es que nos estamos
durmiendo luego se pasa a una otra fase
de un sueño más ligero pero que ya
empieza a ser más profundo de nuestro
cuerpo empieza a acostumbrarse a este a
este proceso y pasamos a una fase de
sueño también más profundo esta línea
larga que ven aquí que puede durar entre
20 y 40 minutos también dependiendo de
en qué momento del sueño estemos que se
cree que es el momento del sueño más
reparador más importante para que
nuestro cuerpo pues se recupere también
así ayude al sistema inmune estamos ya
muy relajados de todos los ritmos bajan
y todo esto antes de llegar a la fase
rem que pues las letras son rapid eye
movement movimiento rápido de ojos todo
esto no es un momento precisamente de
descanso de hecho el cerebro vuelve a
una actividad neuronal muy alta es
cuando soñamos dice creo que es un
momento pues muy importante para el
procesar las emociones también de todo
el día todo este ciclo puede durar entre
unos 90 y unos 120 minutos se repite
como entre 4 o 5 veces a lo largo de la
noche o del tiempo que estemos durmiendo
por eso también son esas necesarias
entre 6 o 8 horas de dormir y además la
fase rem cada vez se intensifica más a
medida que vamos a
pues en el momento de dormir en toda la
noche vamos a hablar de los promedios
marc cuántas personas duermen mal y no
cumplen con estos sitios saquemos a
nosotros de esta lista si nosotros vamos
a formar parte de esos porcentajes sin
ningún lugar a dudas dormimos dormir mal
puede significar muchas cosas no desde
dormir pocas horas tener mala calidad de
sueño tener transtornos incluso como el
insomnio la apnea del sueño entonces
vamos a revisar esos porcentajes
teniendo en cuenta que pueden significar
cosas diferentes hay muchas personas en
el mundo que duermen mal según cifras de
la ms hasta el 40% de las personas
podrían reportar no tener buena calidad
o suficientes horas de sueño y aquí
recogimos varias cifras de encuestas
distintas de lugares de américa latina
vemos que de hecho por ejemplo colombia
desde donde se emite france24 tiene una
de las cifras más altas de personas que
no duermen bien sin embargo de nuevo
estas cifras un poquito con pinzas
porque no son parte del mismo estudio y
puede ser difícil de comparar pero que
al menos nos sirva como referencia de
que no hay una dinámica general de estar
durmiendo bien en el mundo la verdad
consecuencias sobre nuestra salud al
obviamente dormir mal bueno al corto
plazo irritabilidad dificultad de
concentración toma de malas decisiones
también menos reflejos de hecho por eso
se recomienda no conducir por ejemplo si
uno ha tenido no ha tenido una buena
noche de sueño pero también hay
problemas a largo plazo y de hecho estos
son los que pueden ser más preocupantes
se ha asociado a problemas de salud
mental trastornos de ansiedad también
trastornos de depresión de hecho hay
algunos estudios incluso que sugieren
que no dormir bien no limpia las
proteínas que luego están asociadas a
que aparezca alzhéimer en etapas más
avanzadas de la edad y también problemas
físicos más al sistema inmune dolor
crónico pero también enfermedades
cardiovasculares las personas que
duermen mal tienen más riesgos por
ejemplo de tener infartos y eso también
es lo que nos comentaba precisamente la
doctora acabando
que tienen en común y es algo muy
curioso de lo cual también se está en
investigaciones que se genera
como una enfermedad inflamatoria que
básicamente no es que se hinche el
cerebro por decirlo así pero si se
generan sustancias inflamatorias dentro
del cerebro que alteran todas estas las
todas estas funciones diríamos que todos
los órganos son vitales pero realmente
pues ninguno funcionaría si no
tuviéramos un cerebro funcionando marc
qué podemos hacer nosotros para prevenir
estos problemas además de evidentemente
dormir pero como lo logramos claro raúl
es que en realidad tenemos que cuidar el
dormir bien de la misma forma que
cuidamos intentar comer bien o hacer
ejercicio no debería ser una de esas
recomendaciones que se hacen tan
habituales en el mundo entonces déjame
darte algunos tips de algunas
recomendaciones para empezar bueno algo
que nosotros ya no hacemos es no
interrumpir esos ritmos circadianos que
es básicamente como no regula la luz las
horas de sueño porque la noche al final
es el momento en el que el cuerpo
debería estar durmiendo no se asocia se
baja la luz se va a dormir sin embargo
nosotros bueno ya está más trabajar
exactamente sin embargo lo que podemos
hacer es que cuando vamos a dormir
intentar replicar al máximo esas
condiciones bajar la luz que haya un
espacio de tranquilidad que no haya
ruido que nos pueda molestar no intentar
replicar eso también no mirar las
pantallas por ejemplo antes de ir a
dormir es algo que nos puede ayudar a no
interrumpir esos ritmos circadianos
incluso en las personas pues que se van
a dormir a las horas digamos adecuadas y
por último también una recomendación es
que al final debemos escucharnos todos
sabemos en nuestro cuerpo cuando hemos
dormido bien cuando no hemos dormido
bien sabemos qué cosas nos ayudan qué
cosas no por lo tanto hacer caso a ese
conocimiento que también tenemos
nosotros de nuestro propio cuerpo y de
nuestras propias necesidades y cuidar el
sueño de la misma forma que cuidamos
otros hábitos que se consideran
saludable algo tan importante y tan
básico marc pero que realmente nosotros
no escuchamos al cuerpo igual cuando por
ejemplo uno come mal no se has comido
mucha comida chatarra mucha grasa y el
cuerpo te dice nomás del editor como ya
la verdad que me nutre comida limpia la
manera de escuchar todo esto pero
también además nunca soluciona o sea
recordar que también vivimos en un mundo
que no nos facilita escuchar nuestro
cuerpo y no nos fácil dormir bien no nos
no nos saquemos toda la culpa sólo a
nosotros es del mundo exacta mar
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información de salud pasamos a
saludar a nuestro segunda mitad